Bist du in der Lage,
Fake News zu erkennen? Ja klar!
Die Anderen glauben,
was sie glauben wollen!
Aber ich bin rational und kritisch!
Ist das so? Jeder von uns hat
seine Lieblings-Informationsquellen,
denen er vertraut - maiLab - und
andere, denen er nicht vertraut.
maiLab gehört zu Funk - bärks!
Aber seien wir ehrlich:
Mehr als Vertrauen ist es nicht.
Keiner hat die Zeit,
jede Schlagzeile, jeden Artikel
und jede Quelle zu überprüfen.
Wenn Nachrichten Fehler enthalten,
sei es aus Versehen oder vorsätzlich,
also Fake News,
dann ist das ziemlich tückisch.
Weil wir aufgrund von Nachrichten
auch politische Meinungen bilden.
Doch hängt die politische Einstellung
zusammen mit der Fähigkeit,
Fake News von Real News
zu unterscheiden?
Fallen z.B. Menschen
rechts der politischen Mitte
eher auf Fake News herein?
Oder sind es doch die Linken?
Ich bin mir sicher, jeder von euch
hat seine persönliche Vermutung.
Aber bei Vermutungen
müssen wir es nicht belassen.
Denn das Ganze
wurde wissenschaftlich untersucht.
Die Ergebnisse dieser Studie
sind sehr interessant!
Und sie werden euch nicht gefallen.
Der Begriff Fake News ist
inzwischen etwas überstrapaziert.
Ein richtiger politischer
Kampfbegriff ist es geworden.
Ständig werden Meldungen
als Fake News bezeichnet,
obwohl sie eigentlich wahr sind.
Auf der anderen Seite werden
falsche Meldungen als wahr verkauft,
was dann echte Fake News sind.
Seit 2016 ist der Begriff
in aller Munde.
So sehr, dass sich
auch immer häufiger
die Forschung damit beschäftigt.
Hier z.B. habe ich
einen neuen Pre-Print einer Studie
von zwei britischen Forschern.
Ich teile das Ganze auf in zwei Teile
Und ich kann mich kaum entscheiden,
welcher Teil besser ist.
Das erste Experiment führten
die Forscher mit Amerikanern durch.
In Amerika gibt es ja
nur zwei Parteien.
Das macht das ganze
forschungstechnisch einfacher
als z.B. in Deutschland.
Es gibt einmal die Democrats oder
Liberals links der politischen Mitte.
Und die Rebublicans
oder Conservatives
rechts der politischen Mitte.
Für diese Studie schnappte
man sich rund 700 Amerikaner
und erfasste durch einen Fragebogen,
ob sie eher Liberals
oder eher Conservatives waren.
Zusätzlich zu diesen beiden
Schubladen ordnete man die Leute
auch entlang eines Spektrums an,
von volle Kanne Liberal
bis volle Kanne Conservative.
Und auch alles zwischendrin.
Dann bekam jeder Teilnehmer
eine Nachrichtenmeldung vorgelegt.
Und zwar einen Screenshot
einer TV-Nachrichtensendung
und einen kurzen Begleittext.
Wohlgemerkt war aber keiner
dieser Screenshots oder Texte echt.
Nein - doch!
Die Forscher hatten alles erfunden.
Sie haben vier
verschiedene Fake News erstellt.
Jeweils eine positive Meldung
über Obama bzw. Trump,
nämlich eine großzügige Spende.
Und jeweils eine negative Meldung
über Obama bzw. Trump,
nämlich die Verwicklung
in einen Wahlskandal.
Jedem Studienteilnehmer
wurde jetzt zufällig eine
dieser vier Meldungen vorgelegt.
Und sie sollten beurteilen,
für wie glaubwürdig sie
diese erfundene Meldung halten.
Was meint ihr,
wer ist öfter reingefallen?
Liberals oder Conservatives?
Die Antwort ist: beide!
Und zwar gleichermaßen.
Von den linkeren Liberals
wurden die Pro-Obama-
und die Anti-Trump-Story
als glaubwürdiger eingestuft
als von den rechten Conservatives.
Man kann also sagen, die Liberals
fielen bei diesen beiden Storys
eher auf die Fake News herein.
Doch bei der Anti-Obama-
und der Pro-Trump-Story
war es genau andersherum.
Hier schenkten Conservatives
den Meldungen mehr Glauben
als die Liberals.
Als sich die Forscher die Teilnehmer
nicht nur in diesen zwei Lagern,
sondern entlang
des Spektrums ansahen,
wurde dieser Effekt nur größer,
je weiter man sich an das
jeweilige Ende des Spektrums bewegte.
Man kann also sagen:
Je stärker
die politische Überzeugung,
desto größer auch die Neigung,
Fake News zu glauben,
die dieser Überzeugung entsprechen.
Bei einem zweiten Experiment
wurden 570 Briten befragt,
bei denen etwa die Hälfte
gegen den Brexit gestimmt hatte,
die andere Hälfte für den Brexit.
Auch diesen Teilnehmern wurden
erfundene News-Storys präsentiert.
Entweder eine Meldung, die positive
Folgen des Brexit berichtete.
Oder eine, die negative Folgen
des Brexit berichtete.
Selbes Ergebnis: Brexit-Befürworter
glaubten der positiven Story
mehr als der negativen,
Brexit-Gegner genau andersrum.
Das bedeutet, jeder von uns neigt
dazu, Fake News zu glauben,
solange sie in unser Weltbild passen.
Diese Befangenheit,
Einseitigkeit und Voreingenommenheit
nennt man ganz generell Bias.
Je stärker meine politische
Überzeugung, desto größer mein Bias.
Und zwar egal, ob ich eher links
oder rechts eingestellt bin.
Das ist schon ziemlich interessant.
Aber noch interessanter
wird es in Teil 2.
Genauer gesagt:
Wie hängt unser Hang zum Bias
mit unserer Persönlichkeit zusammen?
Jetzt wird es real.
In einem dritten Experiment
rekrutierten die Forscher
900 Amerikaner.
Wieder wurden ihre
politischen Einstellungen erfasst.
Und wieder bekamen die Leute
erfundene News-Storys vorgelegt,
deren Glaubwürdigkeit
sie beurteilen sollten.
Dieses Mal
eine positive Story über Trump
und eine negative Story über Trump.
Nur dieses Mal erfassten die Forscher
zusätzlich zwei Persönlichkeits-
merkmale der Teilnehmer.
Erstens:
Jeder von uns
trifft Entscheidungen
auf verschiedene Art und Weise.
Manche Menschen sind eher rational,
holen gerne möglichst
viele Informationen ein,
um eine Entscheidung zu treffen.
Man sagt, solche Menschen
haben ein hohes Kognitionsbedürfnis.
Auf Englisch: "need for cognition".
Andere Menschen sind eher intuitiv
und entscheiden mehr
aus dem Bauch heraus.
Man sagt, solche Menschen haben
ein hohes Vertrauen in die Intuition.
Oder Englisch: "faith in intuition".
Es gibt dazu einen etablierten
psychologischen Fragebogen,
mit dem man erfassen kann,
wie hoch das Kognitionsbedürfnis
und das Vertrauen
in die Intuition sind.
Dazu muss man angeben,
wie stark bestimmte Aussagen
auf einen zutreffen.
Wie z.B.: "Ich mag komplexe Probleme"
Oder: "Ob ich Leuten vertrauen kann,
sagt mir mein Bauchgefühl".
Wie wirkt sich der kognitive Stil auf
die Beurteilung von Fake News aus?
Nicht so, wie ihr denkt!
Je größer das Kognitionsbedürfnis,
desto größer war auch der Bias.
D.h. Liberals, die sich als besonders
rational und logisch einstuften,
schenkten der Anti-Trump-Story
besonders viel Glauben.
Und der Pro-Trump-Story
besonders wenig.
Bei den Conservatives dieselbe
Geschichte, nur andersrum.
D.h. Menschen, die sich selbst
für rational logisch halten,
denken nicht etwa differenzierter
und sachlicher,
sondern viel stärker
in ihrem eigenen Weltbild.
Und das auf beiden Seiten
des politischen Spektrums.
Warum ist das so?
Ist man vielleicht gar nicht
so rational, wie man selbst denkt?
Eine Hypothese ist,
dass rationale Menschen
zwar tatsächlich dazu neigen,
mehr Infos zu sammeln,
diese Infos aber meistens
ihrem eigenen Weltbild entsprechen,
sodass sich dieses Weltbild
immer mehr verstärkt.
Eine andere Hypothese ist,
dass gerade intelligente Menschen
besonders gut darin sind,
Aussagen, die dem eigenen Weltbild
widersprechen, wegzurationalisieren.
Das finde ich persönlich
besonders beunruhigend.
Denn ich würde mich definitiv als
sehr rationalen Menschen bezeichnen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch ist.
Seid ihr eher rational oder intuitiv?
Stimmt hier oben ab!
Und was sind eure Hypothesen
für dieses Ergebnis?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Dafür neigen die mit besonders großem
Vertrauen in die Intuition dazu,
den erfundenen News-Storys generell
mehr Glauben zu schenken.
Und dieser generelle Trend
war bei den Conservatives
etwas stärker ausgeprägt
als bei den Liberals.
Aber passt auf, es geht noch weiter!
Das zweite Persönlichkeitsmerkmal,
das die Forscher
bei den Teilnehmern erfassten,
war "collective narcissism",
kollektiver Narzissmus.
Also: Ein Narzisst
fühlt sich anderen überlegen.
Ein kollektiver Narzisst
tut das nicht unbedingt.
Aber dafür glaubt er,
dass die Gruppe, der er angehört,
als Kollektiv, als Gruppe
besser ist als andere Gruppen.
D.h., je mehr ein Trump-Supporter
überzeugt ist,
dass Trump-Supporter als Gruppe
Trump-Gegnern überlegen sind,
desto höher ist sein
kollektiver Narzissmus.
Auf Fragebögen kann man das
festhalten, indem man die Leute
Aussagen raten lässt wie:
"Wenn Menschen mit meiner politischen
Einstellung die Welt regieren würden,
dann wäre sie eine bessere Welt".
Da denkt man ja leicht
an Klassismus oder Rassismus.
Und assoziiert das vielleicht eher
mit dem rechteren
politischen Spektrum.
Aber diese Studie zeigt was anderes:
Erstens: kollektiver Narzissmus
besteht auf beiden Seiten
des politischen Spektrums.
Und zweitens: je größer
der kollektive Narzissmus,
desto größer auch der Bias.
Und das auch auf beiden Seiten
des politischen Spektrums.
Anders gesagt,
je besser oder überlegener
ich mein eigenes Weltbild finde,
desto eher neige ich dazu,
Fake News zu glauben,
die diesem Weltbild entsprechen.
Dieser Effekt war jetzt bei den
Liberals etwas stärker ausgeprägt
als bei den Conservatives.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
Aber bei kollektivem Narzissmus
muss ich leider sagen: ja!
Wie oft sage ich Sachen wie:
"Die Freunde der Sonne sind
die beste Community der Welt".
Oder: "Wenn alle Kommentarspalten
so wären wie bei maiLab,
wäre das Internet ein besserer Ort".
Das ist meine Überzeugung.
Und es ist kollektiver Narzissmus,
wie er im Buche steht.
Ich glaube, in diesem Fall sogar
gepaart mit normalem Narzissmus.
Fazit: Die Antwort auf die Frage
"Erkennst du Fake News?" lautet:
Wenn sie deinem eigenen Weltbild
entsprechen, wahrscheinlich nicht!
Jeder von uns hat einen Bias,
der unsere Wahrnehmung von Wahrheit
und Fake stark beeinflusst.
Und Psychologen sind sich einig:
Man kann diesen Bias nicht loswerden,
er gehört zum Menschsein dazu.
Und wenn uns diese Studie eins lehrt,
dann ist es Demut.
Denn egal,
welche politische Haltungen man hat:
Wir sind alle gleich doof!
Auch wenn es sich anders anfühlt:
Wir sind nicht so schlau
und die anderen nicht so doof,
wie wir glauben.
Wenn das kein schöner Grund ist,
sich auch mal andere
politische Meinungen anzuhören!
Da fehlen nur noch diese schönen
Worte des fantastischen Bill Nye:
Also, Freunde der Sonne,
begegnet euch mit Respekt.
Hört euch gegenseitig zu.
Wir sehen uns nächsten Donnerstag.
Bis dahin: Bleibt sicher!
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk, 2019.